speaking of the the social media drama I
should mention that I've talked recently
to Gordon a bunch
I've talked to him about talking to you
guys and he's had nothing but really
nice things to say about you Nick Ryan
and he has had nothing but bad things
what were some of the things
um
well let's just go to the social media
first because
the the Social Media stuff that he said
publicly is just like a warm-up it's
like uh foreplay I guess so Gordon sent
you Nikki rod
flowers for Valentine's Day uh posting
on Instagram quote I've been [__] him
in every round in competition since we
met in 2018 the least I can do is buy
him flowers
we didn't get the flowers
yeah
he sent it to the wrong address he did
yeah what do you think he sent it it was
close but it was wrong did you
appreciate the Romantic gesture I did I
was looking forward to the flowers and
potentially chocolates in there but uh
you know it was a bit of a letdown